check this out those aren't familiar the
george floyd trial it's the trial of
derek chavin is is happening now
there's already been thousands of people
protesting and there are fears that
riots are going to break out they're
putting up barricades they're bringing
in 2000 national guard
earlier today jury selection was
happening and
it is particularly boring to watch and
it's really
not like the movies a lot of people
don't don't get this they think it's
going to be like the prosecutor saying
mr juror you tweeted that you were
racist
aha we've caught you it's just very much
like thank you for joining us um
do you think there's anything that might
get in the way of your judgment no i
don't i think i'll do a good job
okay how do you feel about you know the
media's coverage oh i wasn't familiar
it's like oh okay it's like very very
dry and boring something interesting
happened
jack bosobic tweets breaking juror
number eight says he is concerned
rioters will attack his house
if he serves on the jury and his name is
released in the george floyd trial
zobek goes on to say he uh adds he would
be concerned about them coming after his
wife and kids
he's not wrong i i watched a good amount
of the stream today
not i don't think i saw that part but um
there were quite a few people who um
who mentioned that really or like who
mentioned being afraid
wow yeah so right now
you know whenever i talk to lefties
about what's going on with
the riots and black lives matter they
act like it doesn't happen they're like
oh but it was mostly peaceful and it's
like they really do
gobble up the mainstream narrative and
i'm like what does it mean mostly
peaceful
yeah like not peaceful because it was
mostly like so mostly peaceful means
like
as a whole it was violent that mostly
yeah the lawyer was asking people he was
like you know how do you feel about the
fact that they had to put up all this
stuff outside the courthouse to protect
it
wow like does that freak you out does it
make you feel more safe wait they were
asking the jurors that
yeah wow and the guys were like well
more safe i guess oh yeah i saw that i
saw that how do you feel about the fact
that yeah
wow man so so it sounds like it's pretty
good for
derek chavin yeah is that you confirm
that's how you pronounce it as chauvin
i don't know i was saying chauvin like
chauvinism oh yeah i don't know
i don't know where they were
pronunciations here we don't know
whatever uh but check us out so we have
the story from fox news
scary to watch minneapolis business
owners on edge
over possible repeat of riots bar owner
dermot crowley recalls feeling like
nobody was in charge last spring
and he's right man it's not just him
it's a bunch of other people
you've got the police department was
decimated they they defunded the police
they all voted for it then crime and
homicide skyrocketed
and then they were like uh what do we do
and then the the constituents started
complaining and then the the city
council was like bring back the police
and now they got to spend what is it
like six million dollars i think 6.4
6.4 million dollars to bring cops back
right yep
dude is it gonna be like fresh cops like
rookies or are they bringing i think
i think so well i think it'll probably
be a lot of rookies but it'll probably
be like from other departments
they got to offer a lot of money wow
i think you got to be really dumb to
take that job though jeez
could you imagine like there's a guy on
on trial for second-degree murder
and you we can we can criticize you know
i think manslaughter is the argument not
murder at all
but we've already seen the photo they
were trained to do exactly what he did
yeah i don't think that he should even
be found guilty of manslaughter
and i had people to i tweeted this the
other day and of course people are
really upset about it but then
somebody was like well they have to find
him at least guilty of something because
otherwise the city is going to burn
and i was like what the hell kind of
logic is that that's horrible
they're collectivists it is better that
the collective survives
and the individual suffer that's like
that's that's like bismarck
when was it otto von bismarck is that
his name yeah he said it was better that
10 innocent people suffer than one
guilty person escape
it wasn't it the opposite of that though
well the blackstone's formulation is
it is better that ten guilty persons
escape than one innocent person suffer
right this guy was the authoritarian who
was like it is better that ten
innocent people suffer than one guilty
person escape
nah it's like straight up mob roll like
this guy tweeted at me like so earnestly
about it and i was just like
dumbfounded like it takes a lot to shock
me on twitter now like i lurk the pretty
bad weird parts of the internet
but i was like wow people like actually
believe this they actually believe that
whether he's guilty or not is irrelevant
because the city will burn yeah that's
horrible you think he's
not just your opinion is he's not like
what he did because
i don't think he should be found guilty
of anything at all the
knee on the neck for what nine minutes
they were trying to do the nano the next
right the only real argument is did he
do it too
long yeah and the problem with that is
manslaughter is like
basically you are negligent and you
cause someone's death
there's an argument okay that he was
kneeling too long and when george floyd
became unresponsive
they should have been monitoring the
situation better but also i think we
i it's it's it's hard to know man people
seem they see these things
and they're like i know exactly what i
would do that situation you give
somebody
we talked about this we we talked about
the other day you give someone a handgun
has never shot a handgun before and
they're surprised they can't hit
anything with it
and then try and put them in one of
these situations and they think they
know what would happen
for all we know chavin was just like his
mind was going a mile a minute and he's
got people around him screaming and
filming
and so he's just totally pulled from the
moment
and he's he's kneeling on uh on george
floyd because the tr they were trying to
do it
and he did it for several minutes too
long without but the thing is though
like i watched that video and i feel
like i watched a completely different
video than the left
because george floyd was out of control
like what were they supposed to do they
had him in the cop car and then he was
like no i gotta get out i gotta lay down
i got like
he said lay me on the ground three times
and so they keep saying that they were
worried about like excited delirium
because he was clearly on drugs
we're in the middle of pandemic he
wasn't wearing a mask he had the
coronavirus didn't he
yes and so what are they supposed to do
they have to keep that guy's head away
from them
it's a pandemic that's crazy too we're
seeing it everywhere
i saw a toxicology report that said that
he was intoxicated on fentanyl
yeah and other things everything yeah
caffeine he had in his system no there
was like
fentanyl and and like methamphetamines
and caffeine was one too they found
so tucker was bold the tucker said
he did die of overdose but the the
medical examiner said that's not what he
reported
that i guess the general idea from the
medical examiner is
it was a combination of all of these
factors which i guess the suggestion is
if he wasn't restrained that way he
would not have died
oh i see so yeah i saw two medical
examiner reports one was from the family
and they said asphyxiation death and
then another one came out
and said it was a heart failure and that
could have been brought on by the
it was trauma from the neck they said it
was an underlying heart condition with
drugs in the system
and you know combined with the restraint
so i guess the the issue is do you trust
the family when they come out and they
say oh yeah it's exactly what they're
not using
that report i don't trust anyone at face
value i want more
i want to look at all the evidence i
think he's going to
uh well i don't know what's going to
happen i think there's a there's a
strong possibility like we're looking
let me let me pull this jared thing real
quick so i can give some context the
daily mail says
revealed white chemist who thinks black
lives matter is too extreme
and hasn't seen the george floyd video
and woman of color who's related to a
cop are the first two jurors selected in
derek chavin's trial
so that so far i'm like that sounds
favorable for chevin i mean a guy who
thinks black lives matter is too extreme
he's probably approaching this from a
more neutral but
i mean it sounds like he's biased
against black lives matter not that i
think black lives matter will play a big
role in whether or not chavin did right
or wrong because it's not like george
floyd was literally a black lives matter
activist
but then you have this woman who's
related to a cop so to what degree
is she related to him is it like her
uncle she doesn't talk to or is it you
know her brother who tells her stories
every single day
right you know that i think that'll be
interesting
related to a police officer but i think
either way so far this leans in his
favor
especially when you consider all of
these jurors like you were mentioning
have to walk into this building
surrounded by barricades and razor wire
and cops
and then they're like how do you feel
knowing they had to do this
that's crazy and who was it was it was
the defense attorney asking that
that's a great question yeah but his
question i thought he was great i
actually really like the lawyer
i think he's clever the defense guy yeah
i wonder how much the prosecutors really
want to
to sink chavin as well because that's
the thing that's why i say i don't know
what's gonna happen because there's
politics involved
and politics can make this go any
direction yeah it could be
we can't let the city burn so just throw
them throw them the goo lag and throw
away the key
maybe or maybe they're like we're
suffering
the homicide rate is through the roof
the riots are going to happen no matter
what we do yeah
and if we lock this cop up we're not
going to be able to get any more cops in
this city
yeah considering their spending was at
6.4 million i wouldn't be surprised if
they're like
you know throat throw it to the to the
prosecutor just like
you know throw the throw the case let
him win let him get off and then we can
say we did what we're supposed to do
they're gonna write no matter what we do
and then we can tell all the cops don't
worry you won't go to prison
i'm kind of nervous about the juror that
said he was afraid they were gonna
attack his family
if so that means like if he's afraid of
of being
if he's being that sounds like he's
being coerced already like why would you
put a juror on the jury then well why
wouldn't you be afraid that they're
gonna attack your family
i mean people will come to your house
and launch fireworks at it for mean
tweets
i mean
i mean why wouldn't you think that like
minneapolis activists were going to
people's houses they had a doxing
facebook group where they posted
addresses and
different things and people who were
trump supporters like they had a mob go
to somebody's house just because they
had a trump flag last year
i i was we were talking it was last year
was the day that happened to you
and i was talking about how like with
all the riots going on you know at the
house we got to be we got to be careful
and everybody should be
vigilant and you know keep your eyes and
ears open and ready because
we might start seeing these people show
up at houses and i remember some of my
friends were just like i don't think so
man
no look like they're protesting and
riding without going to people's houses
and then like the next like the next day
i see cassandra being like they were at
my house banging on the doors firing
fireworks
and i'm just like let's get that house
look at that yeah
yeah let's go move to the woods i was
covering the riot that night and it was
like two miles to my house you know
where i lived it was
you know pretty close to the white house
and it was the night they burnt that
church
and i was talking to my boyfriend on the
phone and i was like i'm kind of freaked
out i got like
way more specific death threats than
normal today
because i get them all the time but like
people are messaging me like my address
and dming me my address and all this
stuff and i was like i'm a little
worried but i guess i'm gonna go to bed
and then like literally two minutes
after i got off the phone i was here
like
i was like wow and it was fireworks they
were shooting your window
yeah so i heard this car come up and
they like screeched around the corner
and it was right after the riot ended so
i was covering the riot and i was like
okay it looks like it's all done
everybody's
you know settling down it was like four
o'clock in the morning
and then like just minutes later i hear
this car like screech and then slam the
brakes because they lived on a corner
and they like turned that way and then
they get out and like fireworks just
start
launching at my house and then i hear
somebody banging on my window with what
sounded like stick
or something and then you had some media
activists
go around claiming that you made up made
the whole story up yeah he said that
so he said that he talked to my
neighbors who had a black lives matter
flag in their window but
my boyfriend went over there and was
like hey did you
talk to him they were like no nobody
even came here
yeah um fake news and and they came to
like my halloween party and stuff like
i'm friendly with them
yeah and so they were like we'll go on
record saying he's lying if you want
but yeah he claimed that like there was
just happened to be fireworks at my
house
were you at 4am was it first floor yeah
and were there bars on the windows
no so i yeah it was not fun
and my daughter was home that's wick
with that man thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
timcast youtube.comcastill monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you